yeah so let's talk about 2008 uh 09
crisis first and then we'll get to kind
of what's going on now so
in 2008 obviously there was the housing
crisis
uh the government stepped in created a
ton of monetary stimulus
uh every single person who's ever read
any economics book immediately says
if they print a bunch of money we're
going to go to inflation maybe even
hyperinflation
uh right why did you think that uh
qe potentially could cause deflation
and how does that actually work from a
mechanism standpoint
well it was interesting back
then i actually knew a bunch of guys
that worked
friends of mine family friends and a
couple of other friends that worked in
amora in japan
and it was interesting when they first
started ramping up all these big
programs
i started talking to these guys in japan
because they had been doing qe for
like 15 years at this point so kind of
trying to go back
through history and trying to understand
it at sort of an operational level
i talked to these guys and they're
basically like look this thing doesn't
do
any of the stuff that a lot of the
mainstream narratives
imply it doesn't it's not like printing
money
it doesn't make inflation go up it won't
necessarily make the stock market go
up their argument basically was that it
is marginally deflationary because what
they're basically doing
the fed is creating money okay so
they're creating central bank reserves
and basically swapping though they're
purchasing a
like a treasury bond or a
mortgage-backed security from the
private sector
and what that basically is it's a clean
asset swap basically the
the fed prints a reserve swaps it
for a treasury bond but the crucial
thing is that
they take the treasury bond out of the
private sector economy
so it's almost as if the treasury bond
has been
unprinted to some degree it's the fed
takes it
and puts it on their balance sheet and
the fed's balance sheet is
it's like a black hole it's just this
nebulous thing that doesn't exist in the
real economy i mean we could see
the accounting of it it's there but it's
not like the fed isn't going to walmart
and buying things with their balance
sheets so it's like
it's almost like they take the money out
of the or the treasury bonds out of the
private sector
and they bury him in the backyard or
something but the
kicker with it was that what they're
really doing
when they do this is they're taking
interest income out of the private
sector
and so the private sector's incomes
actually go
down so in a sense it's kind of like
it's like they've swapped a checking
account
for a savings account expecting there to
be like some sort of big
rush to go you know now use your
your new checking account to go buy
goods and services so the whole
the whole program in my view is sort of
misguided and i'm
you know it's funny i i know you're a
critic of the fed
and but i'm i'm weirdly also a critic of
the fed in the sense that
i basically think that the fed and a lot
of what it does
is not nearly as impactful or important
as a lot of the mainstream narratives
make it seem
so the fed to me it engages in a lot of
this funny business
with the economy that doesn't really do
all of the things that a lot of people
seem to think it does
so okay this is interesting right
because i actually think that
uh we may agree on the funny business
my perspective is just like they
shouldn't do it i think your perspective
is like
hey they're doing it but it doesn't have
the impact everyone thinks it has
would it be fair to say that you agree
they should do it or you're in the camp
of they should not be doing that stuff
it does depend i think but like i would
have said
in um in 2008 i actually thought that
qe1
was somewhat important in that what they
were doing was they were really trying
to shore up the banking system and the
banking system
was such a cluster at that point that
you needed to do something because the i
mean that's the fed's primary purpose
and i think this is another thing that
some people
i think misunderstand about the fed is
that the fed is basically just
clearing house so they clear payments
for banks
they're the banker for the banking
system basically and
in periods like 2008 the banking system
starts to shut down and that becomes
problematic because
if me and you can't clear a payment
because jp morgan and bank of america
are scared of each other then it causes
all these negative knock-on effects that
you know like your business could start
to fail or you know
potentially shut down for periods of
time just because
the banks are scared of each other and
that's it's idiotic the way that
you know they can even happen so the fed
is just basically a public clearinghouse
that is
it's always open they never shut down so
when jp morgan and bank of america get
scared of each other
the fed comes in and says don't worry
about it
we're going to clear payments and we're
going to make sure
that anthony and cullen don't go out of
business
just because bank of america and jp
morgan are idiots and scared of each
other so
that's the fed's primary role and they
do all this
other stuff that is sort of tangentially
uh supportive of the banking system but
isn't really always necessary like i
would say that qe2
qe3 all the other iterations i would say
even though the version they're doing
now probably a big waste of time um
probably not having a very big impact on
anything really
um and probably to some degree
not necessarily a waste of money but
sort of an unimportant or or yeah
a waste of energy to some degree just
because there are things that they can
do to support the economy
and qe just isn't one of the things
that's very effective
so i i think that a lot of people
understand um you know central banks
basically have these two tools right
they can manipulate interest rates and
they can
print money or quantitative easing and
it feels like
uh over the last um you know really kind
of
12 years or so but but even a little bit
before that
uh the idea of quantitative easing has
not only become
accepted uh we went from emergency
measures to now it's
hey this is part of what they're going
to do at certain times
and i guess the big question most people
have right so
some of the listeners have zero clue how
the fed
actually quote unquote prints money and
then injects it into
the economy you've talked a little bit
about that maybe just explain the actual
mechanism of injecting that liquidity
and then we can get to the
impact of what that does to an economy
in times of recessionary periods
yeah well the fed in its
simplest manner is just a really big
bank and banks have the ability to
create money from thin air literally so
if you and i
go into a bank and we get a loan that
bank
doesn't it they don't create the new
loan
by having deposits necessarily or
multiplying their deposits or anything
like that they're literally
creating a new loan agreement from thin
air and so that deposit a loan
creates a deposit from thin air and it's
only backed by
whatever the agreement underlying that
is that we have some income
and maybe some assets that are backing
the loan or whatever it is
but the the loan itself and the deposit
the new deposit that is created
is created from thin air it is a new
financial asset
and a new financial liability for for
each of us
and so the entire sheet of the entire
economy grows a little bit when that
loan is made
the fed does the same basic thing there
they basically just create
these these financial agreements from
thin
air wherein the the kicker with the fed
is they
have all these private banks that are
basically required to make markets for
them so when the
when the new york fed goes out and they
start implementing
quantitative easing they go in and they
basically order the primary dealers who
are the big banks
that basically make markets for the for
the fed
they're basically ordering them to go
out and purchase bonds and the fed is
giving them
reserve deposits creating reserve
deposits within
the banking system and the banks are are
basically going in and buying the bonds
and swapping those bonds with the new
deposits that the reserves
resulted so the fed sort of forces
the private banking system to be its
market maker
and that's how they create all this new
money
that ends up basically being swapped for
the treasury bonds